[Musique]
on a tous vécu au moins une fois dans sa
vie
une situation qui met mal à l'aise à cet
instant précis il nous tarde qu'une
seule chose c'est de partir pourtant je
vais vous mettre dans cette situation
mais vous ne pouvez pas partir un voisin
à votre gauche
un autre à votre droite la foule
l'obscurité impossible de sortir
et puis si vous avez réservé cette
soirée c'est pour rester
non je vais donc vous parler d'une
petite fille que je connais depuis son
plus jeune âge elle est pour moi la
représentation même de l'invisible elle
s'appelle juliette julian n'a que 6 ans
elle a des rêves plein la tête comme
tous les enfants ses parents elle aime
plus que tout et la joie de vivre rythme
sa vie
pourtant un jour de septembre elles
arrivent aux portes d'un royaume qu'elle
va occuper durant de nombreuses années
le royaume de l'invisible cette petite
princesse se retrouve face à un homme
qui lui demande l'impossible elle n'a le
choix que de répondre à ses moindres
envies ses moindres désirs ses moindres
pulsions une fois dix fois cent fois ces
actes rythme désormais sa vie sous
couverts par le silence
juliette perd peu à peu sa joie de vivre
et cohabite avec ce lourd secret elle
perd ses repères mais c'est malgré tout
de garder la tête haute
elles se sentent de plus en plus
invisibles mais elle se tait elle se
tait pour ne pas faire de peine à ces
deux personnes qui lui sont si chères
ses parents puis l'aide grandi en
pensant qu après tout ben c'est
peut-être ça la vie elle a 13 ans
lorsqu'elle a son premier petit copain
son premier amour elle comprend à ce
moment là que cette situation n'est
normal elle prend conscience qu'on lui a
volé son enfance il lui a pris la plus
jolie partie de sa vie cette
invisibilité la perturbe
mais c'est aussi son principal repaire
[Applaudissements]
ce cataclysme il vient en elle il y
trouve presque son équilibre le jour de
ses 18 ans une de ses meilleures amies
meurt accidentellement une irrépressible
colère contre la vie la submerge
elle décide alors de sortir de ce
silence de parler elle prend son courage
à deux mains et ali va elle raconte
cette malheureuse histoire sans rentrer
dans les détails en attendant qu'une
oreille pour l'écouter ou deux bras pour
la réconforter
rien de plus mais comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
la réponse n'est pas celle qu'elle
attendait que tu as fait ça comme tu le
dis c'est parce qu'il était mais trop
suivi d'un silence ce long silence qui
banalisent les faits afin de les faire
disparaître
par contre parce qu'on le sait tous il
est tellement plus simple de se taire
que d'affronter le problème
cette prise de courage n'a servi à rien
bien au contraire
juliette retourne à ce qu'elle avait
connue elle y replonger personne ne lui
a tendu la main pour la sortir de cet
invisible
elle pense donc qu'elle va devoir y
rester sauf si elle s'en sort par ses
propres moyens de princesse elle devient
alors super héros elle entame le voyage
le plus long et le plus difficile de sa
vie elle traversait d'où ce douloureux
souvenir elle les analyses et les
transforment en rage de vivre cette
énergie devient sa plus grande force et
contre toute attente elle choisit le
chemin du pardon oui elle a pardonné
elle n'a pas pour autant oublié elle ne
lui a pas trouvé d'excusés mais elle a
pardonné ce pardon lui permet de ne plus
laisser place à sa douleur est la
conscience que ce traumatisme est une
mort psychologique mais elle comprend
aussi qu'elle a le droit à une seconde
chance
désormais juliette n'est plus une petite
fille
c'est une femme ultra active
qui a plusieurs entreprises et qui a la
chance de collaborer avec de grandes
marques elle est maman d'une
merveilleuse petite fille c'est aussi
une passionnée elle est mordu de voltige
aérienne et pilote d'avion à ses heures
perdues et elle voyage à travers le
monde
aujourd'hui juliette aurait pu laisser
le passé au passé mais elle ne veut plus
lui donner raison
depuis elle a trouvé aussi l'amour de sa
vie celui qui lui est la guide geiq
chaque jour et qu'elle aime par dessus
tout si ce soir ma parole et entendu
accepté alors juliette pourra sortir de
cet invisible et ce tabou recul
juliette c'est mon deuxième prénom et
c'est mon histoire que je viens de vous
raconter j'ai fait le premier pas il le
fallait mais grâce à vous qui m'écoutent
et qui me regardent et qui est resté
grâce à vous ce soir je sors de cette
invisibilité et à vous les quelques
invisible qui pour y être parmi nous ce
soir je vous le dis c'est possible par
les briser le silence
allez-y vivait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]